etwas glaubt willkommen beim ein video
ich muss ein bisschen leise reden weil
ihr kennt mich natürlich es ist mal
wieder spät noch gar nicht so spielt
heute wir haben als zehn nach zwölf auf
jeden fall kam mir letzten sonntag
montag dienstag keine ahnung
ein video das größte mann der welt und
ich hab dort in die kommentare
geschrieben was ihr noch so von mir
sehen wollt und ein kommentar hat
wirklich überzeugt mit ich glaube
1000mikes oder so da halten mich jemand
geschrieben
macht doch mal den größten orio der welt
und da haben wir gedacht er kommen du
bist alex wie ein genie und machst
einfach den größten orio denn so groß
gab es ihn noch nie etwas hat sich das
hat einfach alles gerät also ich war mal
wieder einkaufen und ich stelle mich
einfach mal vor was ich so eingekauft
habe wir haben jetzt zweimal so orion
kuchen ganz einfach für die füllung also
hier ist wirklich ziemlich viel führung
dabei das heißt die füllung haben wir
schon mal da habe ich eine oreo packen
wohl ganz einfach damit dieser bisschen
zerbrechen können und später in den teig
klein machen kann und dann habe ich
einfach noch meine oma gefragt weil die
macht mal so leckere plätzchen ich so
joel basman auf wie machst du das denn
sortieren wir das dann erklären und ich
habe das einfach hochgerechnet auf das
zwölffache glaube ich und jetzt habe ich
halt so ein zwölffach großen keks berg
zu brauchen wir einmal insgesamt
ungefähr 500 gramm zucker 500 gramm mehl
und einmal ungefähr 250 gramm butter für
die und reckte und 250 gramm butter für
die obere hälfte
warum ich zwei verschiedene habe weiß
ich selber nicht und damit das ganze
noch schön dunkel wird die noble klicks
noch ein bisschen cacau was ist das
board cacau zum backen muss ich auch
nicht dass sowas gibt aber gibt es
anscheinend und damit was denn jetzt den
größten orio der welt ich bin gespannt
ob es klappt aber warum nicht so ich
meine das maueropfer auch gras oder seid
ehrlich ich finde bevor wir anfangen
müsst ihr alle kräfte mal nach oben
geben weil dann fangen wir euch einfach
an
manchmal treffe ich so auch sagen wir
geben werken sind aber egal com
heute also ich würd mal sagen wo wir
fangen einfach mal hier ist die kamera
hier ist der teig ich will gar nicht
viel arbeit wir machen erstmal den teig
schon einfach zu
kg
so leute der erste tag ist fertig sieht
so aus ich habe keine ahnung ob ich das
richtig mache oder nicht ist auf jeden
fall mega fest aber soll es ja auch
glaube ich ich kenne mich mit backen
nicht aus wir machen jetzt einen zweiten
meine hand fällt wegen diesem mixen hier
auch rheines gleich hier haben wir jetzt
so hier im geldbeutel 2 und mit wollte 2
ich muss immer die linse auf jeden fall
mit beutel 2 kann man jetzt dieses creme
links machen und das machen einfach mal
bis gleich okay leute ich hab das eben
schon mal hier alles im kühlschrank
gestellt
dort ist die untere schicht und da die
obere das soll ein bisschen kalt werden
wird sagen jetzt können was rausholen es
ist einfach schon viertel vor zwei das
ist so krass ich mein einer stunde
geht's auch schon gummi zeit auf jeden
fall wir das jetzt raus thuns dortmund
war offen
und dann bin ich echt gespannt ob das
klappt ich glaube an ein versehen sieht
das eigentlich ganz gut aus nur läuft
ein bisschen unter
hey leute ich habe einfach keinen bock
mehr ich habe einfach keinen bock mehr
guckt euch das man was ist das bitte für
eine scheiß füllung ich meine wut der
war doch ein bisschen war ein ganz
bisschen aber die läuft so krass aus sie
kann nix machen
das sieht aus wie weiß nicht wie ich
heiße erläuterung wird kritik ab wenn
ich das hier so qualm sehr nett ich
würde am liebsten einmal drauf schlagen
zwei drei stunden drei stunden 20 könnte
schon im bett liegen was ist das bitte
was was bist du es mir vor allem ihr tut
es auch so leid um diese lebensmittel um
weiß ich ich wollte wirklich essen
aber das geht nicht die sich beides gern
rein aber wie soll ich damit machen
leute so jetzt weiß ich meint gegen ein
mal hier rein
irgendwie muss ich weitermachen mache
ich das
da guckt euch das mal an alter was ist
denn falsch am anfang sah es sogar aus
ich würde es hier von was haye keinen
sinn
ich hätte das abkühlen müssen denke ich
mal und es ist einfach schlecht geworden
wow
sie wurden einfach man was geht ja was
soll ich dazu noch sagen
ich bin mega abgefuckt ohne scheiß also
das jetzt steht die kamera auch noch
schief alles sieht hier aus wie im
saustall ehrlich hätte ich mir schon
alles sparen können aber gut gehört halt
auch mal dazu dass im video an schief
geht was schief gehen kann
ich hoffe es hat euch ein bisschen
gefallen ihr könnt ihr als toast mal
netten kommentar schreiben und mich
vielleicht ein bisschen aufmuntern oder
einen daumen nach oben geben jetzt habe
ich wieder ein grund gefunden warum wir
in daun nach oben gehen könnt nicht
parat
ja das war auf jeden fall mein letztes
video das größte irgendwas von irgendwas
ich habe die schnauze voll davon ohne
scheiß und mir tut es wirklich somit das
so wie er sich das nicht essen kann ja
leute wie gesagt wir sehen uns morgen
kommt vielleicht ein neues video oder
übermorgen ich weiß es nicht genau nimmt
an einem facebook gewinnspiel teil unter
den ersten 25
ganz oben eine facebook seite verlinkt
verlose ich eine playstation 4 pc